plus de 300 masques et 140 lunettes de
protection en provenance du site saint
quentinois de l'entreprise valeo vont
équiper les médecins et professionnels
de santé de l'hôpital privé de l'ouest
parisien
un don effectué en milieu de semaine et
qui vient compléter ceux effectués dans
le reste de l'hexagone
il est normal pour valeo de contribuer à
cet effort de solidarité à travers les
dons comme les masques les lunettes pour
les équipes médicales et les hôpitaux
locaux
il s'agit d'un matériel de dépannage
tout du moins je l'espère en attendant
que les livraisons se fasse plus vus
régulièrement et en quantité suffisante
pour que nos soignants mène à bien leur
mission vitale est quasiment
réquisitionné qu'uniquement % pouvaient
vraiment été quasiment arrêtée au profit
du soin des patients covin l'hôpital
privé de l'ouest parisien peut aussi
compter sur la solidarité des
commerçants locaux qui déposent des
denrées alimentaires pour le personnel
sur le plan médical la clinique privée
kennedy à montélimar dans la drôme
annonce aussi avoir envoyé 12 soignants
vers l'établissement de trappes valeo de
son côté s'est associé au niveau
national avec air liquide le groupe psa
et schneider electric pour aider à la
fabrication de quelques 10000
respirateur d'ici la mi mai un
consortium lancé par le gouvernement
alors que de nombreux hôpitaux sont
aujourd'hui débordé de patients
gravement atteints par le cos vie de 19